enfin il est à moi c'est un livre
magique tous les plans diaboliques que
je crierai de temps se réalise en mai
pour maîtriser son pouvoir nous il me
faut la dernière page et lé tout au fond
de l'océan
protégé par un héros légendaire
arrête de tapoter sur ce cas nous
partons à la bac
on a encore quelques minutes avant
qu'elle arrive je te soutenons le clap
or touché coulé paramount animations et
nickelodeon movies présence de gsk qui
fabrique son doigt je bousille deux
trucs mais c'est pas ta maison tu
bousille pour sauver leur monde tous
avec moi on va récupérer sonic
ils vont débarquer dans le nôtre c'est
quoi cet endroit bizarre en 2015 un
cachalot poilus s'échouer sur la plage
du rouleau découvrez au cinéma et en 3d
un film tellement sexy
j'ai rêvé de toi tout mon ami c'est très
gênant comme situation est tellement
intense
voilà libre à nous d'écrire l'histoire
tant que ça nous plaît que vous allez
passer à la taille supérieure
il doit faire beaucoup de muscu je crois
qu'ils sont dans mon cours de gym
ayrault pas bon
trop bas bob l'eponge le fil bayrou sort
de l'eau en 3d vas-y super beau gosse
des gobelets
on aurait peut-être dû choisir un autre
super pouvoirs pas drik